dans la classe de 4e année de monsieur
jean thomas ici on joue sur des
contenants vie de récupérer tout
marchand crème glacée une enseignante
mais dis moi j'entends des coups d'oeil
queen des fois il se débarrasse de sa
taille et donne j'aime beaucoup le son
que ça peu comme lorsqu'on fait bon pain
quand on est bon ça va comme raisonnée
et j'adore ça le boxeur robin est un
style de musique de rue en mode et on
s'est inspiré de sa dans cette école
ces dérives cherche hadja c'est juste un
peu on reproduit le john line les lignes
des drames car les percussions et mais
avait avec des coûts - pour fabriquer
ses percussions inusité une classe
d'arts plastiques a été mise à
contribution
je voulais que l'on chantera
l'appartenance avec l'enregistrement
fait j'ai demandé une classe d'un projet
d'arts plastiques et ont décoré les des
chaudières
parce que c'était pas très beau cd
chaudat de frais et congelés gelé
insonorisé je vais avec qu'est ce que
j'avais j'ai juste fait le tapis pour
qui pour le coller sur le dessus c'est
vraiment plus agréable écoutez c'est
moins fort on ne joue pas seulement avec
des percussions le professeur tient à ce
que ses élèves se familiarisent avec le
plus d'instruments possible même s'ils
sont plus disponibles
il a même lancé un appel à ses proches
font appel à tous sur facebook je vais
je demande et qui faisait dans la
semitan commencer l'initiative a permis
d'obtenir 10 guitare et aussi de mettre
la main sur des amplificateurs et des
synthétiseurs en plus de récupérer
l'enseignant réparé ouzou les manques
des normes jeu j'ai pas le temps de les
réparer mais je vais le mettre là dessus
je comprends bien vous vous récupérez as
tu seulement tout ouais ouais comme
ramasseur combustible d'instruments de
musique la joyeuse obsession enchante
ses élèves
je laime 10 sur 10 parce que je trouve
que on apprend de nouveaux instruments
et comme caen sera grand en lorsqu'on va
aller comme à la campagne
il me demande de jouer de la guitare et
bien on sera déjà des enfants iront même
jusqu'à vous dire que ce cours est aussi
bon que de la crème glacée ici gelly
jasmin boudreau radio canada montréal